you know was my first guy yesterday Nick
vial dropping the juicy D I'm currently
filming my first guy yesterday the 38
year old former bachelor kissed and told
on a vlog for the collar daddy podcast
we're co-hosts Alex Cooper and Sophia
Franklin had no problem grilling him
confessional went down shortly after the
girls arrived at the studio for his
podcast the vial files though seems safe
to assume they'll appear on a future
episode in the meantime we'll settle for
all the secrets spilled on the vlog
which included a little walk in top you
wanna vlog where Nick quickly dished on
his recent lip lock for Funny or Die
their time yeah okay that's a little TMI
but it's not like Nick has ever been one
to shy away from putting details of his
love life on display I've been through
the ups and downs
I mean you can't win them all there was
of course the Bachelorette vial was a
contestant on both Andi Dorfman and
Kaylin Bristow season
no after a stint on bachelor in paradise
in 2016 vial was named the bachelor and
went on to propose to Vanessa Grimaldi
will you marry me the two split in 2017
if you're gonna be a part of this
franchise you just kind of have to take
things with the grain of salt
here's what vile told et last year about
his current relationship status you're
here in Vegas a lot of ladies are you
guys both single yeah I know it's a
challenge I don't I'm not on any dating
apps nothing I'm like adverse to it you
know I'm open to dating anyone that I
feel connection with